Не минуло і 10 років після скасування призову, як у Німеччині заговорили про його відновлення.
Навіщо знову повертати обов’язкову військову службу?
І як трансформувалась сучасна армія ФРН?
Збройні сили і міністерство оборони ФРН офіційно створили лише через десять років
після закінчення Другої світової війни.
У 1955 році Федеративна Республіка Німеччина також стала членом НАТО.
Участь у бойових операціях за межами країни заборонялась.
Лише через майже 40 років солдати Бундесверу
почали брати участь у міжнародних військових операціях.
На цих кадрах початку 90-их Бундесвер у складі НАТО в тодішній Югославії.
Це було перше з часів Другої світової
бойове завдання німецьких солдатів за кордоном.
Бундесвер був також задіяний у зарубіжних місіях від Афганістану,
Малі та Нігеру до Балкан, Йорданії та Іраку.
Нині понад три тисячі німецьких військовослужбовців
продовжують брати участь у різноманітних місіях за кордоном.
На момент возз’єднання Німеччини у 1990 році загальна чисельність Бундесверу
та Національної народної армії НДР разом складала майже 600 тисяч осіб.
Об’єднувати два війська не стали. Армію колишньої НДР фактично розформували,
лише незначна частка офіцерів зі Східної Німеччини продовжила службу далі.
Поступово після завершення "холодної війни" Бундесвер
суттєво скоротили, і нині загальна чисельність німецької армії складає близько 183 тисяч осіб.
Щоправда, згідно з планами міноборони ФРН,
до 2025 року чисельність армії має збільшитися до 203 тисяч.
У першу чергу, новий персонал набиратимуть у підрозділи з кібербезпеки.
У 2011 році німецьку армію повністю перевели на контрактну основу.
Цьому передувало поступове скорочення строку загального військового обов’язку.
У 60-ті німці служили півтора року, потім 15 місяців, 12, 10, 9 і дійшли аж до пів року.
Перед скасуванням призову Бундесвер фактично вже був професійною армією.
Частка призовників складала лише 15 відсотків, решта - професійні військові
та ще невелика частка тих, хто залишилися на понадстрокову службу.
До зарубіжних місій Бундесверу призовників не беруть, відправляють лише професіоналів.
Останніми роками залучення нових солдатів у Бундесвер, попри масштабні рекламні кампанії,
ускладнюється, зокрема через демографічні зміни в країні.
Крім того, за статистикою кожен четвертий солдат кидає службу після випробувального терміну.
Втім, у Міноборони уточнюють: падає лише число військовослужбовців,
які уклали свій перший контракт.
Кількість тих, хто уклав повторний контракт, залишається більш-менш стабільною
- понад 30 тисяч військовослужбовців
Це доводить, вважають у міноборони ФРН, що Бундесвер
залишається привабливим роботодавцем.
Чимало німецьких політиків виступають за повернення до загальної військової повинності
і скасування призову вважають помилкою.
Приводом до гострої дискусії став нещодавній скандал через неонацистів,
яких виявили в елітному підрозділі Бундесверу.
Деякі німецькі політики досі переконані, що правий екстремізм
потужніше розвивається у професійній армії, ніж в армії за призовом.
Свого часу побоювання радикалізації особового складу армії
були головною причиною того, чому військову повинність у Німеччині скасували лише 2011 року.
Нині ж про ці страхи заговорили з новою силою.
Втім, інші експерти і політики стверджують, що призов не допоможе подолати правий екстремізм.
І робити різкі кроки і знову повертати призов не варто,
бо це негативно позначиться на обороноздатності країни.
Крім того, підживлюють дискусію про призов і плани президента США Дональда Трампа
скоротити американський військовий контингент у Німеччині.
При цьому більшість німців виступають за призов.
За даними останнього соціологічного дослідження на цю тему, яке проводили два роки тому,
55 з половиною відсотків жителів країни висловилися
за відновлення загальної військової повинності.